call me dude Z last night I had a dream
that I was the CEO of a company that
made sugar cones brother
[Laughter]
in the dream I was at the company
Christmas party and I'd just given a
great speech dude then I got too drunk
and wound up putting a sugar cone on my
penis brother
and that offended a lot of people dude
so I was unceremoniously fired and
banned from the entire sugar cone
industry brother but I vowed Revenge
dude
I hired some people to seduce the CEOs
of other sugar cone companies and take
compromising photos of them and sex acts
brother including putting sugar cones on
their penises dude
then I put the pictures online and they
went viral Brother people called it the
sugar cone penis challenge dude everyone
on the internet started doing it and
sales skyrocketed brother they had to
reinstate me as CEO dude